اصيب ثلاثه اسرائيليين جراح احدهم خطر في
قصف تبنته فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
واعتبرته ردا اوليا على استشهاد الاسير
خضر عدنان في سجون الاحتلال بعد اضرابه عن
الطعام لنحو ثلاثه اشهر كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
الظروف التي يعيشها الاف الاسرى
الفلسطينيين في سجون الاحتلال وكيف سينعكس
تحرك الاسرى الفلسطينيين ضد سياسه التنجيل
الاسرائيلي بهم على المشهد الفلسطيني وكيف
نقيم المواقف الامريكيه والدوليه تجاه
تصعيد اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين
هناك 106 معتقلين الان اعتقال اداري في
سجون الاحتلال دون ان يتوجه اي تهمه لهم
وهذا يعني البطش والتنكيل بالفلسطينيين كل
فلسطيني اليوم اصبحت حياته مهدده بالخطر
كل فلسطين معرض للاعتقال دون اي سبب هناك
خطر حقيقي على حياه هؤلاء الاسرى ما لم
نهب اليوم هبه شعب كامل وواحد موحد لي من
اجل اسنادهم واسناد حقهم في الحريه الهدف
الاسرائيليين هو ان يرسل رساله ان اضربتهم
عن الطعام ستموتون او لا يجب ان نقلل من
اهميه من يقف رئاسه الحكومه يعني اغلب
الاضرابات التي خاضها الدكتور الشهيد خضر
عدنان كانت في كذلك في زمن حكومات بنيامين
نتنياهو بل كلها الخمس السابقه كانت في
زمن حكومات بني يميننا النوم بين يمين
نتنياهو ايضا في هذه المرحله لديه معايير
مغيره حتى الاسراءات الامنيه الاستراتيجيه
كانت تبحث عن تصعيد لا يمكن القول انها
كانت لا كانت لم تكن تبحث عن هذا القصير
بالتاكيد هذا هو رد فلسطيني يقول اننا
موحدون في المقاومه وموحدون في الرد على
جرائم اسرائيل ولن يسمح لاسرائيل مره اخرى
بان تستفرد باي فصيله واي طرف او اي شخص
وربما بالاضافه الى وحده الفصائل قد نشهد
وحده الساحات مره اخرى والان هي موجوده في
مازق مازق اعاده هيبه الردع التي يعني
سقطت منها على مدى الاشهر الاخيره وهذا
يعني بشهادات من داخل
الاجهزه الامنيه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
وكذلك يعني بعض الانتقادات التي تنسب لهذا
الائتلاف الفاشل الحكومه الحاليه في نهايه
المطاف علينا ان نتذكر انه مجمل السياسه
الاسرائيليه سياسي عدوانيه اجراميه هدفها
ضم وتهويد الضفه الغربيه بالكامل وهذا ما
يعلنونه لا يخفي يقول بصراحه امام
الفلسطينيين واحد من ثلاثه حلول اما ان
يرحلوا او يرضخوا بشكل كامل للفاشيه
الاسرائيليه او يموتوا
يمكن القول ان يعني هنالك بعض الاعتبارات
التي فقدت بها يعني ذلك الزخم للتصريحات
الامريكيه وتاثيرها حتى في داخل هذه
المنطقه واخذ هذه الاعتبارات بشكل جدي حتى
من الطرفين
وكل ما يريدونه هم واطراف عديده في
المجتمع الغربي تهدئه على حساب الشعب
الفلسطيني يريد هدوء مع استمرار الاستيطان
هدوء مع استمرار للقمع هدوء مع استمرار
الضم والتهويد هدوء بحيث لا يقاوم
الفلسطينيون ما يجري من ضمن واضطهاد لهم
انا اذكر عندما قتلت ثلاث مستعمرات
اسرائيليات قامت الدنيا ولم تقعد
الاستنكارات والشجب والاستنكار ماذا سمعنا
بشان خضر عدنان هذا المناضل الذي استشهد
الان وترك وراءه عائله كبيره لا شيء